at this point in 2009 he was just an
undrafted free agent signed by the
Houston Texans for whom he made four Pro
Bowls in his eight years in the National
Football League he is now turned the
page from playing football to becoming a
musician is album Flamingo and Koval
under the stage name Bobby Fino is
Kelantan number 10 on the iTunes hip-hop
charts on the uninterrupted label we
have Arian Foster here on Rich Eisen
show courtesy sir Doug wise man how you
been it's been well better for having
you sitting here on the show I'm better
officially what where did Oh what have
you always wanted to sing and be a
musician well yeah I mean it's I think
it's something that I always did I would
always did it's like it's kind of the
moniker of the entire project is like
whatever you wanted to do before you had
to keep the lights on and that's what
like I'm trying to inspire people to
return to like whatever that is and for
me it was music and I've been I've
recorded thousands of songs throughout
my lifetime high school college yeah I
started runs like twelve I've always
done it and it was just something that
was a part of me so I felt like I want I
wanted to put out a project while I was
playing but I just the this the songs
they weren't I didn't give him the
quality that I could if I if I well
they're not retired I have the time now
right and so I couldn't give it the love
and the quality that I I wasn't
satisfied with so I you know I waited
until I was retired really dove into it
and it's a really quality project well
the coordinates that you're giving or as
a street corner in in Las Vegas right
now okay and for those who may not know
the Miglin Koval was the intersection
where Tupac was shot at and eventually
died in the hospital so but it was it
was an impactful moment for me in my
life because why because Tupac was such
an important figure for me even though
he wasn't tangible to me it was
something that growing up in a
circumstances I grew up in he provided
that little bit of hope for somebody who
was struggling financially and just in
in a circumstance where you didn't see a
lot of positivity and he just provided
that a little bit of Hope for me you
know it was a young impressionable kid
looking back he said he said and did a
lot of thing
that's beside the point he provided
something for me that at the time was it
was extremely needed and who is Bobby
fee no I mean it's me it's not so where
did the name come from right it's not
like some corny alter-ego this is me but
I just felt like it's not that deep I
don't think the Arian Foster is a real
artistic name what name I needed to
something else and so Bobby came from I
don't know if you know you probably do
Bobby McFerrin he made that song don't
worry be happy that's what he's known
for Bobby McFerrin yeah yeah but if you
if you dig into his catalogue he's like
a vocal virtuoso he's like one of the
best vocalists of all time and so like I
jacked his name as he's got it from him
Bobby McFerrin I mean I would never have
honestly guessed that we because we were
talking pre-show like where did Bobby
Fino come from I were gonna ask you that
yeah definitely did not think that that
would be your answer Bobby McFerrin is
my guy have you ever met I have no okay
tell me about it I mean that was all the
rage in the day he's the man okay
and so Ray Jennings you couldn't go Ray
Jennings your character franco region
Jennings from so acting you haven't
obviously tried your your your shot at
that I still interested in doing that
you know for sure that's just a slow
cook man you know it's just one of those
things where one of those things where
if you if you want to do it you have to
do it consistently if you look back like
in the 90s you'll see actors from today
who are who are excelling but they're
doing these small little parts that
probably you would never even notice
them like I've ever seen Dave Chappelle
and like Robin Hood in tights like you
just don't remember those roles sure
because they were just so small but you
just have to you just have to keep at it
getting small roles small roles and you
know hopefully boom so entering foster
here on the Richardson show aka Bobby
Fino um here on the show so how'd you
get hooked up with maverick Carter and
LeBron how did you get right so um it
was an interrelationship through a
business associate of ours but what
happened was they we my people sent the
the project Flamingo and Koval to their
people and they were automatically
interested I mean III understand the
stigma as far as athletes putting out
music it's usually trashed nitrogenous
trash they heard this and they wanted to
be a part of it because they understood
the quality of and well because they
also looked maverick sat in that seat
yeah and the number of stuff that they
get sent
yeah I cannot imagine who goes through
that before even gets to maverick or
even LeBron I can't even imagine the
filtering process that they go through
yeah they privy to see a lot of so and
there's no disrespect I think you know
artists subjective but I feel like
there's a level of quality that's
respectful to the art form itself that
people who make actual music for a
living can respect like one of the
biggest the biggest compliment I've had
was to my favorite producers today hit
me and said you know this is this is
dope it's a hit boy he's Grammy winning
producer and then a 9th wonder he posted
on on Instagram and I was like a little
kid in shell shock cuz I guess when I
looked at it he's been making hits for
artists for years and it's just it was
it was a form of validation for me but
to answer your question um they heard
the quality and they wanted to get
involved and then I have a song where I
sampled a jay-z interview and I had to
get that cleared through his his people
and the people from title as well heard
the song wanted to hear the project and
then they wanted to help with the
rollout so I had an interrupted and
title who believed in the project can
help with the rollout so it's just a
little step but still of approval of how
quality the music is and I say that
humbly I'm really a humble cat but like
I you get that darlin you have to
differentiate yourself from the box that
people are gonna put you in initially so
so does this require you root for the
Cleveland Cavaliers is that anything is
it that in the fine prints no but I just
I refer I refer Braun period I was a
Laker fan but it's just where I want you
might be able to match the two by July
first I think he's going to LA but is
that inside label and is
I have a podcast as well it's called now
what does another plug but um Matt Matt
was on it too and we talked about that
he didn't want to even want to spill the
beans either but as I tried to get that
I don't feel like there's another media
market that can handle him and I think
he has like two houses or something like
another well yeah and then I also
pointed out that you know he if he does
want to get into the entertainment world
which clearly he does starting a label
he's doing all sorts of stuff I'm like
Menelaus perfect yeah you know and then
maverick as well as only he can and just
sign it kind of cut you down to size in
about two seconds yeah well rich you
know you can have meetings anywhere
people come to wherever he goes so it is
true you know this is the mecca of
entertainment for sure Arian Foster here
on the Rich Eisen show do you agree that
age 34 running backs in the NFL that
that's an age by which you can pretty
much say somebody's career is done based
on your experience no not necessarily
I think there have been a lot of
productive thirty year old running backs
I think it it definitely it's a factor I
think age 34 athletes in general is just
the you know careful around LeBrons
label I mean he's I mean your life is
the spectrum right so you always have
your outliers and he's beyond an outlier
he's breaking records at age 33 it's
insane but it's just it's just powerful
you can't be father time like we all
grind as long as we can and so what
advice would you give living on Bill
wants to be paid more like like a wide
receiver or a top running back it's
tough I mean I disagree with how the
structure of the NFL is paid in the
first place so it's hard for me to how
so well we don't have guarantee
guarantee contracts I think that the NFL
PA and the owners they're not doing any
justice to the players and they say
they're all for player safety the player
health and player all that but they're
not they're obviously not and the way
that they're paid reflects that the way
that they're treated is reflective of
that so it's it's it's not something
that I
and I mean you gonna have a tough time
getting paid as a running back you have
to be super special and he is but the
way that they're doing them now is is is
is it's wrong the Texas took care of me
like they could have put the franchise
tag on me and you could do it like two
or three years or something like that
and like the way they're doing them now
is like if you if you want to take care
of your place take care your players but
they did take care of you they signed
usual took care of me after you
certainly proved yourself or so and he's
proved into so it's like they should
pony up the dope but I mean okay that's
the life I want to take a quick break
come back I want to talk about your love
of fantasy football oh yeah did you hear
the did you hear the sarcasm drip into
the microphone here I mean I thought
you're a musician you're a person who
can understand timbre or voice that and
then the whole awesome anti awesome
moment which was great for me I remember
I think I showed an MRI of my hamstring
on total access that night it was epic
thank you we'll be back on the Bobby
Fino show in a moment don't worry be
happy you did you always have that in
the NFL yeah it's a journey it's
definitely a process man you loved
fantasy football right it was one of the
I woke up every morning and thought
about trying to make people happy I'm
finished football it was I loved it it
was amazing how much would you always
hear about that every day I still hear
about it do you really yeah then you're
on the green room I heard about it come
on TJ do that well our social media
coordinator you did you once you still
get thanked for winning yeah he made me
give another percentage but but you
didn't
and all deep down that that that why did
you dislike fantasy football um as a
young player I did I dislike I hated it
but as a little older player and as a
grown man out of out of the game now I
understand its value but before all I
saw was the dehumanization of players
like that's all I saw it was like if if
you got injured this oh you ruined my
fantasy bum yeah yeah you know and it
was like it was like that kind of stuff
rather than like imagine going to work
and you have two ambulances on either
side of your office and like they're
there because somebody's probably gonna
get hurt and then you get chastised for
being hurt it's too crazy as I did to me
but it's something that you had to deal
with but like I understood its its value
later on in my career and afterwards and
then you just take it real light-hearted
why did you tweet out your MRI because
was there something going on with you
and the team where you thought you
thought that they were not you know I'm
not as hurt as you thought I wasn't it
was a hamstring pool but I think it was
um it I didn't think it would be as big
a deal as it was like there were team
meet we had a team meeting about it it
was what do you mean here the team
meeting we had to see meaning about like
he pulled a team together can't be doing
this kind of stuff yeah daddy got is it
Romeo was that no it was cool Kubiak
okay Kubiak yeah that's my guy do you
know preface it with that that's my guy
okay but uh yeah it was a bit as a huge
deal was like all over every talk show
and I was like I had no idea was maybe
it was just it was just a random like
funny thing I did on social media it
wasn't like I don't know so that you
just decided I'm gonna tweet out my my
own personal information I mean it's a
picture of a x-ray of a hamstring so
it's not like I wasn't happy what do hit
what do people think everything's look
like is McNary your guy Bob McNair
you're not it's not my guy but I mean I
don't have any problems with them well
what do you think about this whole
kerfuffle of him saying great work in
the asylum that's a great word you like
kerfuffle that's a good what should be
the name of your next stop I don't think
so but uh
but no I mean obviously there there are
two sides of the coin here there's one
that says it's a it's a it's it's a it's
an idiom it's just a phrasing of words
that doesn't have any real substance
behind it any age running this money
yeah and then there's people that say
there's some context behind that that
you should be more responsible with what
you're saying I tend to lean more
towards that side but I'm open to
hearing the other side and I think in
general how I view ownership in the NFL
and the way they view their players it
makes sense it's I think it aligns with
their ideals but I don't think there's
an owner that will sit down and have a
dialogue with a player to sort out those
those those issues you don't think
there's any owners that would I don't
think so
well some owners did sit down with some
of the players in in New York I'm
talking about I gonna put in a public
forum because I think I think that's
that's what's important as I mean as
well as those private conversations but
I'm sitting down like in a public forum
and having those that discourse because
the the issue within today's society is
you have a politically infused society
and social media is fueling that fire
and so that that kind of discourse can
help people in their day-to-day lives
have those conversations with their
bosses with whoever they have because
that's that's this is society we live in
you have to have these conversations we
just live in that world now would you
have taken a knee if you were playing
like I did take a knee you did yeah I
was when I was in Miami I did take any
so that was in your last season yeah did
Stephen Ross say anything to you
yeah he came up to me the day before and
he said I appreciate what you're doing
which is weird cuz I think I'm not I'm
gonna show but any kind of backtracking
you say well he was he was saying what I
think some owners are saying and I'm I
don't have it off the top of my head so
I'm in that that at this point in time
the issues have now been conflated to
the point where why keep doing it right
yeah is what he I think is what he was
saying right I don't I don't know I
don't get it but I understand what he's
saying I think
like I said he came with me said I
appreciate what you're doing he was big
in social activism I think to the point
now it's you keep doing it because
that's what the freedom of the that's
what you have in this in this country is
the freedom to do so you protest at your
will and any any disdain for that I
think is ignorant of of what the gesture
is in the first place
I don't I don't think it's a form of
disrespect I've talked to military that
think it is I talk to military I think
it isn't round around we go this that's
what America is this melting pot of
ideas but I think if you continue the
narrative you should be able to do and
feel as you please as long as you're not
harmony brushes on there now you have
about a minute left and I know that
that's this is bigger subject if the
league takes the stance that every team
can have their own rule on it whether
you stand or sit how do you think that
would sit with players I don't think
it'll sit well I think I think that if
you're forcing if you're fortunate if
you're forcing patriotism on the league
in the first place by an annual budget
that the government has to fly planes
over to do the national anthem to do
flags then you're forcing a political
statement in itself so if that's a
political statement and you're trying to
stay out of politics and take that out
as well and if and if not then you can't
you can't be opposed to two players
taking political stances on things that
they believe in check out Flamingo and
Koval on iTunes
rice on iTunes Spotify title especially
title uh you know all streaming
platforms whatever you stream you sure
uninterrupted
obviously and look under the name Bobby
Bobby no fee so if you look at Aaron
foster you won't find it so you're
saying no you're not gonna find it man
that's that's a that's a that's called
branding right there well one in a sense
it's now what with Arian Foster the
podcast definitely have a podcast and we
have interesting guests I know
come on the pot Wow Jesus I mean thanks
for the invite you know for sure one out
the door we just released one today we
have bomani Jones on so ok so good
conversation let's do that complete the
home and home will make it have you've
been here I do I do your podcast and
then we keep going on and on and and I
race you in the forty well I mean how
much of a head start you're gonna you're
gonna give me no head start well I will
suit your suit I wear
I don't even have a shoe so I'll get a
suit for it and the slippers that you're
wearing right now we've open toe
slippers open toe slip of that guy's
okay
check out Aaron for Arian Foster on
Twitter check out again Flamingo and
Koval or where music is streamed great
to see you my husband got it Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience